Podcast UFO, Podcast UFO, Podcast UFO, mit Florentin Will und Florentin Will. Podcast UFO. Für alle, die jetzt vielleicht über die Feiertage ein bisschen, ein paar bisschen Gedächtnisverlust betrieben haben, noch mal ganz kurz hier zur Erinnerung, was machen wir überhaupt? Was ist das Podcast-UFO? Das ist immer das Intro. Lurin und Schuhemann brauchen Geld, machen einen Podcast? Amazing! Hallo, jetzt kommen die, jetzt kommen wir, jetzt kommen die Echten, Achtung, herzlich willkommen zum Podcast-UFO mit Stefan Titzlingheimer und Stefan Titzlingheimer. Es wurden alle Namen vielmehr erwähnt. Ja, vielen Dank für das fantastische Intro. Das, glaube ich, Stefan absolut verwirrt zurückgelassen hat und wahrscheinlich viele von unseren Hörerinnen und Hörern auch, aber da müsst ihr jetzt alleine durch. Vielen Dank an Lucia, Hannes, Lee und Moritz. Was? Ein
Quattro, ein Quattruple?
Eine absolute Koproduktion.
Wahnsinn. Also Konzeption, Lucia,
Hannes hat die Komposition ausgebaut,
Lee hat sich um einen Ort gekümmert
und Moritz war eher so für die Stimmung
da. Ah, und ich sehe, Sie wollen noch der Medienstiftung
Berlin-Brandenburg danken
und der Hof, auf dem Sie das
Ganze aufnehmen konnten, da haben Sie nämlich eine, das ist der Hof Kaltern bei, in der Uckermark und da wollen sie sich bedanken, weil sie da einen Monat lang Rick Rubin getroffen haben, um herauszufinden, wie man so einen tollen Song komponiert und sind da in so ein Trainingscamp gegangen und haben das dann aufgenommen. Also vielen Dank an diese grossartige, manchmal hört man nicht, also nicht despektierlich so was klingen, aber man hört dann gar nicht, weil es klingt so einfach und so schmissig, aber man hört gar nicht, wie viel Arbeit dahinter steckt. Absolut, und sie schreiben auch, sie widmen diesen Song Frau Rampozetti, das ist ihre alte Erdkundelehrerin, die dieses Jahr leider verstorben ist. Okay, man sollte Menschen vorher viel eher was widmen. Ja, meinst du? Ja, wenn man denen was widmet, wenn sie schon tot sind, können sie das nicht, ja, per Definition nicht mehr feststellen. Okay, also du sagst, gucken wann stirbt jemand und kurz davor noch rein. Schmeißt das rein. Schnell davor noch rein, auch wenn der Song noch nicht fertig ist vielleicht, wenn ihr noch kein Refrain habt, aber ihr merkt, die Person baut ab. Stark ab. Lieber schnell nochmal raushauen und dann kannst du ja nach dem Tod noch eine zweite Version rausbringen.r doktor sieht es denn aus weil ich habe noch keinen refrain es sieht ganz ganz schlecht aus
also hier noch keinen refrain ja also wir rechnen herr jovi wir rechnen noch mit ungefähr ja acht neun stunden weil also die respirative beatmungs lungen einfacher für mich sprechen ich bin ein einfacher Musiker. Ach so, ja das wird schwächer und deswegen in ein paar Stunden glaube ich noch ein paar Stunden, also es ist nicht mehr lang. Hat Bon Jovi sich überlegt, ich brauche Strophe, Refrain, Strophe, Refrain, Chorus, also Bridge, Refrain, Refrain, eine Quarte höher.
Hat er so über Songs, glaubst du, nachgedacht? Ich glaube ja, ich glaube, der war sehr technisch und hat dann irgendwie gesagt, Moment mal, ich kann ja den Refrain beim zweiten Mal einfach nochmal verwenden. Da ist ja quasi jetzt schon der halbe Song fertig. Ich hätte schon mal eine Pause machen, aber ich hätte schon den halben Song eigentlich. Aber unsere Musiklehrerin damals, Frau Rampuzetti hat gesagt,
niemals zweimal das gleiche benutzen im Song.
Naja, aber sie liegt schon lange unter der Erde.
Fuck her.
Und damit stirbt. Dieser Song ist für dich.
Und damit sterben unsere Ketten.
Und damit sind wir befreit.
So ging Bon Jovi los.
Bon-Vorname, Jovi-vi Nachname. John Bon Jovi. John Bon ist der Vorname. Nee, John Bon ist der zweite Vorname. Ja, Bon ist der zweite Vorname und Jovi ist der Nachname. John Bon Jovi. Boah, es ist so gut. JBJ. Es klingt so gut, es fließt so durch. Es ist richtig gut. Genau wie Eddie Van Halen, finde ich auch. John Bon Jovi, Eddie Van Halen, Barack Obama. Das sind so die grossen Rolling-Namen. Die guten Namen, ja, wo man wirklich sagt, genial, wo man wirklich mit der Feder am Papier sitzt und sagt, Barack. Barack Obama. Eigentlich muss ein Name so sein, dass man nicht genau weiss, wo der Vorname aufhört oder nach dem Anwesen.
Exakt.
Das muss so ein Fluss sein.
Helena Bonham Carter, so, naja, das ist Chloe Grace Moretz.
ja das ist so abgetrennt das gefällt mir nicht auch nicht. Das muss fließen. Wie Nickelodeon. Oh, Nickelodeon. Ist der Fahanname noch frei? Nickelodeon Tietze? Nick-i-Lodeon. Ist das wirklich gegründet worden im Netzwerk von Nick-i-Lodeon? Nein. Das ist ein altes Gerät. Man hat sich dafür einen extra sperrigen Namen überlegt. Das ist, ich weiss, es ist schwer, Comedy zu machen mit jemandem, der einfach alle Fakten hat. Der alles weiß. Tut mir leid, aber nee. Seit 300 Folgen versuche ich hier einen Witz aus diesem Podcast heraus. Wir sind, das ist der Podcast, der von dem einen, der Comedy machen will, ich, und gegenüber Professor Doktor Weizsäcker, der alles weiß. Genau. Seit Jahren versuchen wir diesen, und es fällt mir schwer, wir haben noch nicht einmal einen Gag gemacht, weil sie alles wissen. Naja, also der, weil sie haben ja gesagt, also der Himmel ist ja deswegen blau, weil die Licht, das einfallende Licht der Sonne wird in der Art gebrochen, dass das blaue Licht sozusagen das Auge erreicht. Ja, ich dachte auch, er wäre blau wegen Alkohol, blau. Genau, sie haben gesagt, er ist blau, aber es hat er getrunken. Aber das hat damit tatsächlich gar nichts zu tun. Und tatsächlich, wenn man sagt, ein Mensch ist blau, dann wird er auch nicht tatsächlich blau. Das ist eine Redensart, die kommt aus dem Französisch. Ja, ich weiß, ich versuche hier auch ein bisschen, die Stimmung hochzuhalten. Und von ihm kommt halt gar nichts. Ja, ich finde, Wissen macht auch Spaß. Also ich finde, das ist ja auch eine Art von Unterhaltung, oder nicht? Also ich meine, die Hörerinnen und Hörer wollen ja auch was lernen. Okay, ich würde nur sagen, Barack Obama ist ein lustiger Name, weil er so fliesst. Okay? Genau, phonetisch hängt es nämlich damit zusammen, dass die Endung auf einem Vokal kann sozusagen direkt in den Konsonanten von Baracko. Ja, genau. Und deswegen habe ich gesagt, Nick E. Lodeon war bestimmt einfach, das ist der coolste Name der Welt. Ich kann den Artikel einfach nochmal vorlesen mit Nick Elodian, weil das ist faktisch einfach nicht korrekt. Können Sie die 20 Minuten Zitatangaben danach einfach lassen diesmal, weil es ist trocken. Okay, dann machen wir es heute mal kurz. Es ist ja trocken. Ist ja immer noch Unterhaltung. Das ist im Grunde unser Reddit. Ich will wie so ein Comedy-Typ ankämpfen gegen Wissen. Ja, wirklich. Weil genau genommen das Wissen, genau Faktentreue ist der Tod eines ... Ja, Fakten sind der Tod des Spasses. Des Genitiv Esses. Des Spasses. Ja, genau. Der Genitiv ist der Tod des Spasses. Des Genitiv Esses. Ja, Esses. Des Esses. Ich bin kein Fan des Genitiv Esses. Ich habe einen Kumpel, der Max heisst, und dann hat er sich nur in sein Macbook eingeloggt und dann stand da ganz gross Max's Macbook Pro. Also, aber auch, das stimmt ja gar nichts. Ganz unangenehm, ganz unangenehm. Und auch das Macbook so zwei S, drei S, Max's S, das ist... Max's, es ist M-A-X-S, was aussieht wie ein polnischer anderer Vorname. Matsch. Matsch, her wie kommen Matsch? Matsch Macbook, Matschis Macbook, Matschis Macbook Pro, Matschis Macbook Pro, Matsch Krabatski. Der gleiche Witz, wer den Polen gemacht wird, jetzt sieht es aus wie ein tschechischer Vorname. Und die Tschechen lachen, es klingt wie ein polnischer Vorname. Es gibt jetzt ein großer Kreis grosser Kreislauf. Ja, der ganze Balkan ist ein grosser Witz. Was? Das sagt man, das darfst du so nie wieder sagen. So, sorry, Entschuldigung. Hä, wie, wirtschaftlich? Ein Kreiswitz, ne, naja, aber auch kulturell. Was? Im Sinne der sprachlichen Entwicklung, weil es ist ja eine grosse Suppe, aber es ist ja alles mit einzelnen Brocken. Der Balkan ist ein Witz, eine grosse Suppe ist wirtschaftlich und kulturell ein Witz, hast du gerade gesagt. Das Gute ist, dass sich niemand als der Balkan definiert. Ich glaube, niemand ist wütend. Weißt du, wie wenn du sagst, die dritte Welt, da sagt niemand, Mann, hey! Ich glaube, niemand identifiziert sich als das, sondern man sagt einfach es sind immer die anderen. Es wird vor allem hier drüber gesprochen, wo nicht dritte Welt ist. Das heißt, Leute fühlen sich nicht angegriffen, weil sie gar nicht wissen, dass über sie als dritte Welt gesprochen wird, meinst du? Ja. Ich glaube, dass sie im Balkan genau wissen, dass sie im Balkan sind. Und wir kriegen jetzt richtig viele Balkaneinschriften. 16 Lkw fahren gerade an unserem Studio vorbei, einfach alle mit so Gesichtern drauf, mit so 16 verschiedenen Gesichtern. Und ein Gesicht ist von Stefan. Ein Lkw? Er versucht sich zu erinnern. Habe ich jemals für so eine Tiefkühlfirma gemoddet? Eigentlich nicht. Ich bin diesen Monat, an den ich mich nach wie vor nicht erinnere. Und du erfährst immer weiter, was dort passiert sein muss in diesem Monat. Du hast was auf und hast Segelschein in der Hand und hast dann irgendwie so, kannst stricken plötzlich. Und du weißt, Moment, dann muss ich in dem Monat stricken gerne haben. Das war ja, das war Mai 2022. 2021. Ist komplett ausratiert. Und ich erinnere mich daran nicht mehr. Jetzt sehe ich aber ab und zu, sehe ich mich modelnd auf Litfaas-Säulen. Und ich dachte, manchmal ist es okay für sowas wie Almi-Joghurt oder so Almi-Gurt. Ja, du lächelnd einfach. Aber neulich war das so ein bisschen knapperes Höschen. Und da habe ich gesagt, brauche ich jetzt nicht unbedingt. Aber gut. Ich habe dich letztens gesehen auf diesem Erotik-Adventskalender. Eis.de bei Amorelin. Das weiß ich nicht mehr genau. Und ich sage mal, das 24. Türchen war dein Schritt. Du hast nur meinen Schritt gesehen. Kannst du bitte? Nein, nein, dein Foto von dir war auf dem Cover des Adventskalenders und das vierund... Das bin nicht ich! Aber du hast doch gerade ausgemacht! Das vierund... Aber nicht für dich! Und das vierundzwanzigste Türchen war genau dein Schritt. Und dann dachte ich, ah, das ist ja... Okay, das muss ich mir kurz aufschreiben, weil das kann ich noch nicht. Genau, genau. Ich glaube, das war eher so Anfang Mai. Es war eher so, glaube ich, du hattest noch längere Haare als auf dem Almigurt. Ich glaube, das war, du warst im Mai beim Friseur und hast erst diesen Erotik-Schut gehabt und dann hast du die Haare geschnitten und dann den Almigurt-Schut. Genau, das kommt bei der Timeline sonst nicht hin, weil der Almigurt, da war ich noch nicht so braun. Und es gibt nämlich, da gab es diese Unaccounted-for-Urlaubszeit auf dem Malediven.
Hattest du die Narbe schon auf dem Almijoghurt-Poster?
Boah, ich glaube ja. Also man sieht nämlich so ein bisschen Retusche.
Ah, okay, man sieht Photoshop, da wurde so ein bisschen gewischt.
Ja, naja, also es ist noch nach wie vor ein großes Geheimnis für mich.
Falls ihr im Mai 2021 Stefan gesehen habt, bitte meldet euch. Aber habe ich tatsächlich gesehen an der Kasse Erotik-Adventskalender und da waren schon zwei weg. Aber ich dachte mir, das wirklich ... Das Podcast-Ufer habt ihr ja seit Jahren kennengelernt als FSK drei. Ja, stimmt. FSK sechs. Ja, genau. In den letzten Folgen haben wir ein paar Hörerinnen und Hörer bemerkt, es ist nicht schlüpfrig, aber wir haben immer so ein Thema drin.
Wir kommen langsam in die Pubertät, ja.
Weil wir haben nächstes Jahr zehn Jahre das Podcast-Ufo und man muss echt mal überlegen, wir kommen langsam in ein Alter, wo wir auch mal so ein bisschen die Schmuddelhefte raussuchen. Wir sind langsam geschlechtsreif und wollen das auch zeigen. Wir wollen das auch zeigen, aber genau, okay, ich finde es nämlich spannend. Dieser Erotik-Adventsender, also wo man ohnehin schon fragt, okay, es ist noch nicht mal Dezember, da sind Leute jetzt wirklich ... Wollen wir diese ... Halt, stopp, die Gag-Polizei kommt rein, oh nein, oh nein, Herr Anwalt, nee, wir machen keine Gags über zu frühe Adventsklamotten. Nee, nee, das meine ich gar nicht. Okay, nur das klar ist, wenn die Kuchen oder so zu, nee, nee, nee, nee, stopp. Oder so früh bei Rewe, mal das Bankertoffeln. Nein, nein, nein, überhaupt nicht. Da können wir den Laden zumachen. Ich habe das unterschrieben und daran halte ich mich auch und wir machen keine Gags über, es ist ja erst August, was soll ich jetzt mit Dominos Stein? Okay, okay, halt euch zusammen. Okay, ja, ja, Sir. Ich meine, es ist gut, dass wir ihn haben, aber man muss ja so aggressiv sein. Er kommt immer mit seiner Energie, er kommt so direkt mit seiner Krawatte schon rein, wo man denkt. Vor allem, das ist schlimmer geworden, habe ich das Gefühl. Seit er seinen Hund verloren hat. Ach was. Ja, der wurde angefahren. Kennst du ihn privat? Der Hund wurde angefahren bei uns im Parkplatz. Auf dem Parkplatz? Ja, ich war dabei. Aber da fährt man doch eher langsam auf dem Parkplatz, oder nicht?
Ja, ich war dabei.
Also ich habe es gesehen.
Also ich war sehr nah am Geschehen dran.
Da fährt man eher langsam.
Und dann ist der ganz langsam über den Hund drüber, oder wie ist er darin gestorben?
Ehe genau, der Hund ist so wie so eine Zahnpasta-Tube.
Ach Gott, nein.
Und warum warst du vor Ort? Ich war das Auto. Das Auto. VW, der ist jetzt neun war. Ich habe jetzt neun Auto. VW, das Auto. Ich war das Auto. Auto. Auto. Baby. Ich habe neulich ein lustiges Video gesehen von so einer deutschen lustigen Jungsgruppe bei einem Bierabend. Boah, geil, schön mit den Jungs, mit Rudi, mit Bernhard und mit Juan. Und Dingo. Und dann fragt man sich so, man wäre gerne dabei, so eine Gruppe war das, hat eine gute Zeit. Und dann war die Tagline, warum können alle Jungs in Deutschland diese Synchronstimme? Und es war diese lustige Synchronstimme, die jeder kann. So dieser, dieser, weiß ich nicht, dieser Held, dieser klassische Tim-Thaler-artige Whatever, Held einer jeden Animationsserie. Genau, aber es ist einerseits dieser Florian David Fitz, dieses, hey Leuteute ich glaube wir müssen unbedingt weitermachen aber auf jeden fall wir kriegen das hin aber es ist auch dieser otto clemens artige tiefe synchron sprecher das auto aber das weiß ich nicht ob es jeder kann ist es ein unterschied aber diese gruppe hat alle haben diesen protagonisten artigen ja animationscharacter hinbekommen zu synchronisieren, das kann jeder, weil es einfach nicht so viel ist. Es ist nur diese... Ja, genau, es ist gar nicht eine Stimmungsveränderung, sondern eine... Also man fällt ja die Stimmung, nicht die Stimmung. Es ist eher so ein, hey Leute, wir müssen unbedingt gucken, wie es weitergeht. Das kann doch nicht sein. Das kann doch nicht sein. Und es macht einfach immer Spaß. Es macht immer Spaß eine jungsgruppe die sich dann so so in den schritt haut und dann alle so eine art von gruppe die dann so wenn diese bierflaschen haben dann hauen die da so oben drauf ja und dann spritzt es raus und dann haben sie sich, warum hauen wir das nicht wieder in den Schritt?
War was da, was meinst du?
Was hast du gerade gesagt?
Nee, weil das ist auch lustig mit dem Draufhauen.
Alter, mega lustig, Alter, das hat sich ja voll ins Gesicht gerotzt rein.
Wie wieder?
Aber warum hauen wir uns nicht einfach wieder in den Schritt, das war einfach gefallen.
Jetzt, wo du es so sagst, ist es irgendwie komisch wir das eigentlich ja warum machen wir das um uns warum sind wir so wird mit uns und unseren körpern und warum können wir nicht einfach normal miteinander umgehen und so oder ist doch auch okay wenn jemand vielleicht gefühle für den anderen hier hat, oder? Naja, es ist ja,
das eine ist ja das Körperliche, das andere ist ja das Emotionale, aber es ist ja...
Genau, aber warum sich einfach alle wieder in den Schritt hauen?
Ich habe morgen auch noch nichts,
also wenn ihr heute keine Lust hat, wenn ihr darauf habt,
dann habt ihr morgen wieder Lust, vielleicht so ein Akkuding,
was wieder aufgeladen werden muss,
weil ihr alle gerade so
ruhig werdet und nicht mehr so darauf reagiert. Wir können uns morgen treffen, ich habe nichts vor, oder Dienstag, um uns alle in den Schritt zu hauen die ganze Zeit.
Meinen Eltern geht es nicht gut gerade. Es ist gerade eine Phase, wo es schwierig ist für mich. Deswegen ist es für mich auch mit den Jungs gerade so
mein Auffangbecken irgendwie.
Verstehe ich. Ach krass.
Hey, komm mal her.
Sorry, ja, es ist,
sie weiss noch nicht, mit wem ich drüber reden soll und
da finde ich es einfach cool, dass ich
euch habe, dass ich mich
dann auch so ein bisschen fallen lassen kann.
Vielleicht sollten wir mehr über unsere Gefühle reden, anstatt uns in den Schitz zu hauen. Aber lass uns auch noch... Genau, das finde ich jetzt gut, wenn wir über die Gefühle sprechen, dass wir eine Bierflasche und so brauche ich nicht in diesem ganzen Bro-Talk oder diesem Gym-Kram. Ich würde gerne an der Flasche festhalten. Ich finde, das ist ein liebgewonnenes Ritual. Das haben wir mit dabei verstanden. Aber ja, ich finde, vielleicht was ich rausnehmen würde, ist das mit diesem am Finger ziehen und dann furzen.
Das finde ich hat für mich irgendwie, das hat für mich irgendwie nach 16.000 Mal sich das dann doch irgendwie für mich auserzählt.
Oder?
Ja, ich finde es okay, können wir verlieren.
Okay, dann lass uns das rausnehmen. Genau, ich habe auch einen Überfokus auf diese eine Sache. Ja. Okay. Diese modernen, ist schon toll, dass wir inzwischen reden, auch männeröbliche Gefühle. Ja, total. Weil diese Jungsgruppen, weißt du? Wenn die Instagram-Kamera ausgeht, dann können die sich wirklich alles erzählen. Genau. Davor ist erst mal aber danach können die sich auch wirklich in den Arm nehmen. Es war ja nicht so ein gröliges, broiges sondern es war ja auch ein aber wir machen Synchronsprecher nach. Ach ja, es hat mehr Theater AG, also dafür wäre ich früher geflamed worden, vermutlich. Geflamed, okay. Gesteinigt worden. Verbrannt worden. Ganz früher. Wenn mich jemand fragt, würdest du behaupten, du bist katholisch erzogen worden oder christlich erzogen worden, würde ich immer sagen, nein. Aber jetzt habe ich, weil mein Elternhaus wird verkauft und da habe ich jetzt auch viel ausgeräumt schon. Es wird sich durchziehen die nächsten Folgen, freut euch auf viel Material und Kindergeschichten, die ich gefunden habe.
Du hast ja die ganze VHS schon digitalisiert.
Genau, die Wunschliste ist schon auch ein bisschen am Start, dieses Projekt. Und ich habe so viele, weil ich war im evangelischen Kindergarten, ich dachte, das ist eher so ein Label, was draufhängt, aber was nicht wirklich in Kraft tritt. Aber ich habe so viele das kleine Gebetsbuch von Stefan mit so Malereien von mir gefunden.
Oh ja. was draufhängt, aber was nicht wirklich in Kraft tritt. Aber ich habe so viele das kleine Gebetsbuch von Stefan mit so Malereien von mir gefunden und so und ich habe dann so Bibelzeichnungen gemalt und so und dann dachte ich, was ist das für ein Mann mit Ländenschurz, den ich gemalt habe, am Strand stehend? Ich dachte, what the fuck is this? Und dann stand drüber, Mose. Aber so auch von dem Erwachsenen wurde es draufgeschrieben, Aber jetzt, warte mal, nur für uns, war Mose nicht der Genitiv? Der Weg Mose. Es war auch Mose ein Anschlusszeichen. Weil der heißt doch Moses. Das ist ja im Althebräischen, es ist ja genau anders als im Deutschen. Da nimmst du für den Genitiv das S weg. Hier steht das S weg. Also du sagst, der Leidensweg Jesu. Also du nimmst das S weg, damit du den Genitiv hast. Genau. Und dann sagst du, ja, der Strandurlaub Mose. Aber der Typ heißt Moses. Genau. Nicht Strandurlaub. Nein, nein, das war nicht der Strandurlaub. Das war es in einem Moment. Ach so, am Wasser, am Wasser. Genau, ja, ja, ja. Ja, aber er mochte noch mehr Strand. Der sagt, warum ist hier mehr? Ich will mehr Strand haben, weg mit dem Wasser. Ich habe als Kind auch den wichtigen Part dieses Bildes vergessen, der Mehrteilen-Part. Bei mir ist einfach nur, Moses steht am Strand. Aber es war vielleicht das erste Panel von vielen, dann hattest du keine Lust mehr und hast gesagt, so geht's los. Es sah aus wie ein vollwertiges Bild, wo ein massiver Bestand, deswegen war auch glaube ich so von diesem Erwachsenen so relativ, sagen wir mal, despektierlich mit Anführungszeichen Mose drüber geschrieben worden. Auch gut, dass du ihn wie so ein Steinzeitmenschen malst, mit Ländenschurzen, einfach als hätte man keine Kleidung gehabt, einfach. Ja, aber ich fand es sehr erschreckend, wie viel so religiöster Kram. Das ist bei dir noch irgendwo drin. Ja, habe ich auch gedacht. Auch so Schuldfragen, wenn du, also du bist ja oft sehr selbstkritisch und ah, dafür werde ich schmoren und so, also dieses Selbstgeißelnde, das hast du schon noch ganz viel drin. Also ich sehe da noch ganz viel Katholizismus bei dir. Ja. Ich finde es auch sehr spannend, also vermutlich muss ich noch ein bisschen aufräumen in mir und so ein bisschen reflektieren. Wenn ich eine interessante Reise, nimm uns auf die gerne mit. Okay, wir fangen nochmal an. Sorry. Wir fangen nochmal an. So weit weg. Ich habe Witt gesagt. Also ich finde das M und das W sind das so Mario-Vario, das sind so Gegenteile. Nimm uns doch da gerne Witt. Scheiße. Stell dir vor, du bist, keine Ahnung, Olaf Scholz und du musst wirklich kämpfen. Das Land braucht dich jetzt und du kannst jetzt nicht alle im Stich lassen und so. Es geht um diese eine grosse Wahl, die du jetzt sonst, sonst kommt, whatever, an die Macht. Deswegen musst du richtig kämpfen und du schaffst es auch, die Rede ist super und cool. Und deswegen nehme ich euch jetzt alle, Witt, ist dein letzter Satz. Und alle waren eigentlich gut drauf und dachten so, wow, alle waren bereit für einen grossen Applaus und er verspricht sich beim letzten Wort. Er schaut so in die Rede und unten steht, während tosendem Applaus winken.
Ja.
Und er schaut hoch und es ist still.
Nehme ich jetzt, müssen wir uns, nehmen wir uns alle, Witt.
Und ich nehme jeden einzelnen von euch, Witt.
Mit. Mit. Danke. Ich habe jetzt das gemacht, was wahrscheinlich die meisten Leute irgendwann machen, nämlich ihr Audible-Konto kündigen, weil die einfach mich ausgesaugt haben wie ein Vampir. Und dann habe ich in die Audible-App geguckt, dann hatte ich noch Guthaben übrig, weil da muss man monatlich zahlen und kriegt dann so Guthaben, mit denen man Hörbücher runterladen kann.
Und dann hatte ich noch ein Guthaben übrig und dann gab es ein Buch, das ich gerne gehört hätte, das gab es aber nicht. Und dann dachte ich mir, was mache ich jetzt mit einem einen Guthaben? Ich habe ein Hörbuch frei. Kannst du mir schenken? Was? Ne, ich habe es schon ausgegeben. Ich habe überlegt, was kann man dafür, also was ist ergiebig? Das ist so, wenn du noch einen Gutschein hast bei einem Laden, wo du nie hingehst, dann kaufst du irgendwie Klopapier oder irgendwas, was man halt einfach immer braucht, wo man jetzt einfach sagt, das ist ergiebig, das braucht man immer im Haus. Evergreen. Evergreen, das ist einfach nie schlecht. Und was ist das jetzt in Hörbuchform? Bibel. Und dann habe ich mir Rufus Beck liest die Bibel. Nein, nein, nein, nein, ja, aber ich verstehe es, ich verstehe es komplett. Ich dachte mir, bevor ich jetzt sage, Harry Potter 5 nochmal, dachte ich mir, nee, dann hab einfach mal die, hab einfach mal die Bibel Teil 1 und Rufus Beck irgendwie neun Stunden oder neun, ganz, ganz viele, ne neun auf jeden Fall dabei und neun Stunden wäre, glaube ich, nicht so viel. Nee. Und jetzt habe ich die Bibel auf dem Handy, habe nicht wirklich vor, sie zu hören, aber ich dachte mir, ist es immer gut, wenn man die hat, wenn jemand dann irgendwie so einen Korinther-Gag macht und du und dann in der U-Bahn nach Hause jetzt lass mich noch mal kurz nachblättern. Korinther-Witz. Korinther. Aber das ist ja fantastisch. Ich finde das eine super spannende Reise. Vielleicht kriegen wir die aneinander geknüpft, wenn du jetzt Bibelfest wirst undensichtlich viele so Gebetsschild drin ist. Kann ich dir erklären, wo deine Schuldkomplexe herkommen, von welchen Gebeten da? Ja, das finde ich super. Also wenn man von mir kriegt jetzt jede Woche so eine Kindergeschichte. Ich habe auch meine Herr-der-Ringe-Geschichte wiedergefunden. Nein, wirklich? Mit der Armbrust und der Spitzhacke? Genau, und du hast meinen Rechen. Sowas, also ich habe ja früher als Kind Herr der Ringe basically nachgeschrieben. Gut, ich würde als, ich weiß nicht, siebenjähriger, sechsjähriger, da ist wir am Ende wieder sprechen und sagen, ich habe meine eigene Geschichte erfunden. In einer Zeit, in der du Herr der Ringe konsumiert hast. Genau. Zeitlich hat sich das überschnitten, aber inhaltlich nicht. Und dann gibt es so eine kleine Dina-Vier-Zettel, wo ich dann eine Karte aufgemalt habe. Ach süß. Der Hauptstadt ist Kronerde, heißt es. Es heißt Kronerde und es gibt die Hauptstadt, heißt Grieria. Grieria, geil. Durch die fließt der Mittelfluss. Okay, also statt Mittelerde hast du Mittelfluss. Ja, Kronerde ist Mittelerde, genau.
Und dann gibt es natürlich so ein böses, dunkles, mit Bergen umgebenes Dorf.
Ja, das heißt wie?
Darkmeer.
Ah, geil.
Sehr schön.
Das kannst du alles irgendwann mitbringen.
Das ist alles Bonus-Content.
Aber ich finde es gut, dass du gesagt hast, so ein kleiner Diner-Vierzettel. Du brauchst keine... Es war nur ein kleiner Diner-Vierzettel. Ja, auch Schimoron. Du brauchst die Angabe nicht mehr. Ja, ja, hatte ich ja so einen kleinen Diner-Vierzettel dabei. Nee, brauchst du nicht sagen, wir wissen alle, wie gross Diner-Vierzettel sind. Das ist wirklich genormt einfach. Ja, genau. Ja, ja. Kennt ihr so einen, habt ihr einfach so einen gross kleinen DIN-A4-Zettel dabei. Nee, brauchst du nicht sagen, wir wissen alle, wie gross ein DIN-A4-Zettel sind. Das ist wirklich genormt einfach. Ja, genau. Kennt es, wenn ihr so einen, hab ich einfach so einen grossen DIN-A4-Zettel in der Hand, wie soll ich den vollbekommen? Dann kam der da mit so einem riesigen DIN-A4-Zettel rein und ich dachte mir, was passiert denn jetzt? Naja, es kann schon einen Geisteszustand beschreiben. Ah, für einen DIN-A4-Zettel kommt der mir jetzt gross vor. Sehr gross vor. Ich sag mal, wenn du jetzt, wenn du was schreiben sollst, hast du keine Idee, dann hast du einen grossen Diener-Vier-Zettel vor dir. Verstehe, okay. Aber eine Speisekarte ist manchmal ein kleines Diener-Vier, weil man denkt, eigentlich müsste da, ich hab nicht genug. Exakt, und für Kronerde und diese geballte kreative Power, die da drin reinfloss, dafür ist ein kleiner Diener-Vier-Zettel. Ja, okay, ich verstehe schon, das ist eher dann eine subjektive Betrachtung. Eine subjektive. Der Norm. Eine subjektive Betrachtung der Norm. Ausdruckstanz. Ja, das bringe ich mal mit. Aber cool, das hast du dir die Bibel gekauft. Hast du schon reingehört? Ich habe sie gedownloadet, alles gedownloadet. Dein Handy ist doch jetzt voll. Und es ist randvoll, randvoll mit Psalmen und Versen. Und ich habe noch nicht reingehört, ich habe in die Hörprobe reingehört, weil ich mir dachte, worum gehst grob? Und was suchen die aus als Hörprobe? Ja, das ist eine gute Frage. Das ist so, dass man sagt, was stellt man ins Schaufenster der Bibel? Was druckt man auf Cover? Welche Szene würde man aufs Cover drucken? Und die Hörprobe hat einfach direkt am Anfang angefangen. Weil man sagt, das ist schon Wort Gottes so, lass uns nicht ausweitreffen, weil ist alles gut. haben, wie es anfängt. Und deine Anfangen mit sieben Tage, das kennt man halt.
Aber ja, ich werde mal reinhören und gucken. Ich glaube, das kann man kurz gut
gut weghören, weil es auch so kleine
knackige Geschichten sind.
Aber ich weiß relativ wenig, aber ich habe Bock drauf, weil es gibt ja auch in jedem Buch, das alt ist, gibt es so Szenen, die man nicht mehr versteht oder so. Du kennst ja so die Klassiker und für den Religionsunterricht werden wahrscheinlich so die rausgezogen, die man checkt irgendwie mit den sieben Ährenkörnern oder der Brände Busch, halt so die Klassiker.
Aber dann gibt es ja bestimmt auch ganz viele so B-Side-Stories, wo man einfach denkt, es gibt die Marvin, so in der gekürzten Fassung, wo man gar nicht mehr checkt, was das soll, weil auch irgendwie ein Übersetzungsfehler. glaube ich. Und dann sprechen irgendwie Rosinen und man denkt, ist das ein Übersetzungsfehler oder was?
Oder ist das der Stamm der Rosinen oder sollen jetzt wirklich Rosinen sprechen? Die Rosinerinnen. Ist das jetzt ein... Das sind rein weibliche Kampfkrieger, die Rosinerinnen. Genau, die Rosinerinnen und wurden nach denen jetzt die Rosinen benannt. Es waren Rosinen. Moment, es waren weibliche, aber es waren we Storys habe ich Bock. Es gibt nur weibliche Rosinen. Moment mal, die Männchen sind Weintrauben, die Weibchen sind Rosinen? Ja, oder Pflaumen, oder Zwetschgen. Ich hätte dieses Buch nie in die Hand nehmen. Ja, aber ich glaube, es gibt, also ich ich glaube für gerade so Kinder, die dann mit einem kleinen Gebetsbuch rumlaufen, denen wurden vor allem die Storys rausgesucht mit einer klaren Lehre. Ja. So fabelmässig, ne, am Ende steht dann irgendwie, und dann hat Jesus stand vor der Wahl, weil sich Leute wütend zu machen oder nicht geliebt zu werden und jemandem zu helfen, entscheidet sich für das Richtige oder sowas. So kleine dramaturgische Bögen. So und ich glaube, dass es viele Storys gibt, die nicht so sind. Nee, überhaupt nicht. Die kann nichts führen, wo auch etwas fehlt, wo ein Augentur, ein Zeitzeuge fehlte oder so, oder die, keine Ahnung, hast du die Geschichte schon draufgeschrieben über den Briefkasten und der Autor so, ach, äh, äh, ja, ja, genau. Weil du sollst dir morgen abgeben. Richtig, richtig, der Briefkasten und der Autor so ach äh äh ja ja genau, weil du sollst dir morgen abgeheben richtig, richtig, der Briefkasten, der die Briefe isst weil die so lecker sind genau, wo Jesus dann eingreift und dann genau, dann will der eigentlich einen Brief an seine Jünger schicken, aber die werden dann aufgegessen vom, okay, nee, weil und die Pointe war die Lehre weißt doch, weißt doch jeder, Jeder weiss die Pointe von dem Briefkastendeck. Genau. Und dann kam halt für die Zeit nichts. Absoluter Quatsch. Kompletter Nonsens. Ich habe auch mal gelesen, dass es ein großes Problem war, in der Bibelforschung zu entscheiden, wann ein Absatz aufhört und wann der nächste anfängt. Weil es anscheinend irgendwie einfach eine lange, eine 800 Kilometer lange Papyrusrolle war ursprünglich und die einfach durchgehender Flchen. Hm, ähm, ich höre besser ohne meine Brille offensichtlich. Aber Augustinarius, sie können, sie müssen nicht. Mein Name aussprechen dauert elf Jahre. Augustinarius der Weise, sie müssen nicht immer Return drücken, sie können auch Shift returnen ganze Wörter, weil ich seit zwei Wochen drücken sie nur Return. Ja eben, weil es hier, es ist auch nicht keine Absätze drin, seht ihr das? Ja, ja. Ich habe der Weise, zwar in meinem Titel, aber eigentlich bist du der Weise. Oh, danke. Du kannst mir mit diesen technischen Problemen so gut helfen. Der Bescheidener wäre vielleicht was für dich. So, ja Leute, der IT-Experte was für dich. Okay. Technik. So, gibt es noch andere Mönche hier oder nur uns? Wollen wir uns in den Schritt hauen? Locker machen wir eigentlich das. Klar, auf jeden Fall. Und deswegen bin ich auch gespannt, ob ich vielleicht eine Neuinterpretation der Bibel präsentieren kann, weil ich sage, nee, die eine Geschichte hört da noch gar nicht auf, sondern die geht überhaupt bis dahin, weil manchmal müssen die ja einen Punkt machen, hier hört die eine Geschichte auf und die nächste geht los, aber das ist manchmal gar nicht so klar, was jetzt noch genau dazugehört, weil es ja, würden ja nicht ständig die Namen gesagt, sondern er ging und dann war und dann, wer ist jetzt gemeint, wo hört das auf? Ja. Ah, ah Gott, man, schreib doch mal dazu. Hey, ruhig dich. Oh, ey, sorry. Ruhig dich, ey. Mann, ey, als die Leute zu mir gesagt haben, Markus, schreib die Bibel, dachte ich mir, das wird ein super einfacher Gig, da ist irgendwie Geld dahinter, aber der schreibt nur Quatsch, ey. Wer? Ich muss da, Gott, ich redigier das die ganze Zeit um, da sind Schreibfehler drin. Aber der ist doch allmächtig. Da sind Schreibfehler drin. Ja, dachte ich auch. Ich dachte, das wird ein einfaches Ding. Da sind Schreibfehler drin, da sind Grammatikfehler drin. Kannst du nicht mit der Asche bitte auf die? Ja, ja, ja. Kannst du, weißt du, das ist einfach viel zu viel. Du hast mir den Gig an Land gezogen. Du bist ein schlechter Agent, Mann. Ja, voll, ist doch Gig, Mann. Du hast mir gesagt, das wird ein einfaches Ding.
Du schreibst die Geschichte Gottes, der Typ ist allmächtig, der Alte ist allmächtig.
Also wie schwer kann es sein, einen Text von einem Allmächtigen zu kontrollieren?
Ja, liest das mal hier durch. Sieben Rosinerinnen kamen nach Bethlehem und frugen, wo sind die Pflaumen.
Was soll das bedeuten?
Naja, ich glaube, du hast sowohl Rosinerin als auch Pflaumen falsch übersetzt.
Mein Hebräisch ist auch schon eingerostet.
Und dann gibt es wirklich, das wäre meine Aufgabe für dich, meine Hausaufgabe für dich beim Hören der Bibel wäre, gibt es denn wirklich einen Bibelcode?
Okay, nochmal Da Vinci, nochmal.
Ja, so ein Da Vinci-artigen Dan Brown Bibelcode, ah krass, Armageddon ist am bla bla bla bla
11. März
2034, sowas.
Das finde ich schön. Eine Schatzkarte
oder irgendwie. Genau, Schatzkarte, grosses rotes
X und so. Vielleicht, weil du das
hörst, hast du einen anderen
Zugang oder sowas und du merkst, ah krass,
die Anfangsbuchstaben eines jeden Kapitels
ergeben.
Das ist ja beim Hören ja besonders leicht, sich die Anfangsbuchstaben jedes Kapititels ergeben. Das ist ja beim Hören ja besonders leicht,
sich die Anfangsbuchstaben jedes Kapitels zu merken.
Genau.
Okay.
Sowas irgendwie, dass du dann uns einen Bibelcode vortragen kannst.
Finde ich gut.
Ich werde es suchen und vielleicht werde ich fündig
und vielleicht können wir dadurch ja Weihnachten besser verstehen
und verstehen, warum wir einen Erotik-Adventskalender
zu Weihnachten bekommen haben.
Du hast ihn nämlich gesehen an der Redenklasse.
Ich habe ihn gesehen an der Kasse.
Und deswegen, das merkt man, ohne Scheiß, komm mal her,
ich finde es so toll, dass du dir jetzt diesen roten Faden nochmal,
weil ich wusste, seit zehn Minuten denke ich mir, wo kommen wir her, wo kommen wir her, wo kommen wir her.
Und dann hat man neun Jahre Podcast-Erfahrung, wisst ihr, das kriegt ihr bei uns nicht,
das kriegt ihr bei uns nicht, wir machen diesen Bonus seit zehn Jahren
und wir können uns jetzt zum ersten Mal, nach neuneinhalb jahren können wir uns gro erinnern woher wir kamen mit dieser wohlstrukturierten ausflucht einer geschichte und dann wurde es nämlich so stark und professionell der kommt darauf zurück na klar ich lasse euch doch nicht hängen nein ist doch klar we got you obwohl das ja vielleicht so ein bisschen der kern von erotik ist mal antiesen. Mal was hängen lassen? Mal was hängen lassen. Mal erst mal was antiesen und dann 20 Minuten lang hängen lassen. Und dann erst mal 20 Minuten lang gar nichts machen. Ja, nee, wie gesagt. Und dann denken, wurde es vergessen, habe ich das geträumt und dann plötzlich kommt es wieder zu. Babe, das ist nicht der Sinn von Erotik, habe ich dir auch schon mal gesagt. Hä, nee, aber. Etwas anzuteasen und dann 10 Minuten hängen zu lassen ist nicht. Naja, aber du weißt gar nicht, oh, geht's noch weiter oder warst du es schon oder geht's diese Spannung, diese Spannung, diese Spannung, er sitzt schon wieder am Laptop, geht's noch weiter, wahrscheinlich nicht, vermutlich nicht, das ist für mich Erotik und ist dann die Regec, sie macht sich dann ein Gerät an der Marke. Ich dachte, das ist der Drucker. Okay. Der Marke. Na, vielleicht machen sich manche den Drucker an. Hier könnte ihre Erotik-Brand wegklingen. Erst mal, ich bin jetzt, sage ich mal, nicht ganz neu im Erotik-Business. Im Spielzeug-Game. Aber 24 verschiedene, wow. Also was ist da die Idee? Ja, ich war auch nicht davor. Die ersten 18 sind Kondome, ich weiß nicht genau, was genau das ist, aber mich wundert einfach alles an diesem Ding.
Einerseits finde ich es cool, dass Leute anscheinend zum Supermarkt gehen und sich ein Erotik-Adventskalender einfach aufs Fliessband legen und sagen, das ist es, das ist es einfach. ohne Scham, ohne Häme, ohne zu wissen, was da drin ist, weil du hast ja gar keine Ahnung,
sondern sagst, das ist jetzt genau die Idee. Vor allem für mich wäre das nicht so ein Impulsivkauf. Ich würde mir legen, ich würde vielleicht mal gerne unser Sexleben irgendwie so ein bisschen erweitern, fände es mal ganz interessant, dann bestelle ich mir so einen Eventskalender. Aber an der Kasse zu stehen mit der Haarmilch in der Hand und zu sagen, ach komm, schmeiß rein, schmeiß rein in den Einkaufswagen,
ganz merkwürdiger Zustand, in dem dieser Mensch ist.
Zumal wir leben in einer Zeit, wo es das Internet gibt.
Richtig.
Leute bestellen sich Bücher, die nun wirklich es nicht unbedingt Sinn machen,
im Internet zu bestellen.
So, dann kauft er den fucking im Supermarkt, nicht im Supermarkt.
Ja.
Und stellt dann diesen Riesen vor. Die sind auch gross. Also es gibt diesen Eis-Deer-Benz-Kand-Kalender. Ich meine, 24 Dildos, das ist eine... Dilden. Dilden, Entschuldigung. Das ist eine Menge. Also, ich habe mich vor dem gleichen Paket gestanden und gedacht, schon auch spannend war. Weil, weiss ich nicht, kurz, Oversharing, not a toys guy. Kein Fan. Aber ich finde es sowieso spannend, das alles mal zumindest mal zu sehen. Auf jeden Fall, aber jeden Tag? Nein. Also das ist ja dann schon ein Commitment, wo man sagt, also du kannst, ist es dann so, packt man dann aus und sagt, ach, das machen wir am Donnerstag und dann sammelst du. Donnerstag haben wir schon den Analplag jetzt. Ja, aber wir können das ja beid, also wir können ja Nee, wir haben Donnerstag den Analplag und die Massagekerze angemacht. Okay. Also wir können nicht jeden Tag alles immer auf Donnerstag schieben. Ja, aber wir sind jetzt schon vier Tage hinterher, wir haben jetzt schon vier Türchen aufgemacht und wir haben es noch nicht verwendet. Und heute war der Humanizer drin. Ja. Heute bin ich mal dran. Okay, das freut mich für dich, aber dann bleibt halt alles am 24. hängen. Da kommen meine Eltern aber schon um neun Uhr morgens, das habe ich dir auch gesagt. Ja, und dann waren wir am 22. zwölf verschiedene Toys. Du hast mir nie zu. Das ist genau so, stelle ich mir. Ja, und das ist dann so die Werbung. Ja, ja, mitten im Satz. Also ich sehe hier folgendes, weil ich habe mich auch gefragt, was ist denn da alles drin? Und es gibt diesen Eis.de oder Amorelie, Adventskalender, whatever. Oder Ficken, Ficken, Ficken.de, halt einen von denen. Und die sind alle, die sind auch teilweise sehr teuer. Hier steht oben drüber, Warenwert 900 Euro. Die kosten dann irgendwie 200 Euro und es ist glaube ich wirklich einfach ein krasser Warenwert.
Moment mal, was ist denn 900 durch 24? Was ist denn denn der einzelne? Leute, ey, was ist das denn für eine Frage? Na ja, komm Stefan, das kriegst du ja hin. Das sind ungefähr 30, sind 30 Euro ungefähr. 37,5 Euro pro Dilden. Ach so. na ja und was hier so drin ist ist eigentlich die Klassiker. Also das Ding ist ja, nur weil man jetzt auf ein Toy steht zum Beispiel, heisst das ja nicht, dass man die ganze Welt des, der, des, der Légion, wie heisst das, so Reizwäschekram oder sowas, oder so dieses alte, burleskhafte, weiss ich nicht.
Aber da kann doch keine Kleidung drin sein, oder? Du trafst doch nicht nach Größen.
Nee, genau. Aber ich meine nur so, wenn du halt auf einem Sexspaßteil stehst.
Absolut, ja.
Kein ist nicht, dass du auch, ach ich liebe Massagen, ich liebe BDSM.
Ja, ich glaube die Idee ist, dass du es halt so ein bisschen ausprobierst. Aber ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass die Redaktion nicht beim Aufschreiben bei Platz vierzehn sagt, fuck, wir haben nichts mehr. Sollen wir nochmal nochmal? Also ich sehe hier. Dann irgendwie die Feder oder was auch immer. Ich sehe Kitzelfeder, ich sehe klassischen Dildo, ich sehe Analplag, ich sehe Penisring, Ich sehe dann wirklich so ein Dessou, dann auch Massageöle. Aber welche Grösse erstmal? Massageöle. Welche Grösse? Das ist der grösste Fauxpas, den du machen kannst, dass dann da irgendwie so Reizwäsche drin ist, die dann nicht passt. Das ist das Schlimmste, was passieren kann. Ja, also das ... Dann sehe ich so Vibratoren. Ja. Dann so eine Kugel. Vermutlich vibriert die auch. Alles vibriert. Alles vibriert, oder? Auch die Wäsche. Auch die Wäsche, Massage, alles. Ist ja heutzutage kein Problem mehr, oder? Du kannst ja eigentlich bei allem sagen, soll es auch vibrieren? Der Chefingenieur kommt immer, soll es vibrieren? Wieso? Nee, es ist nicht. fünf minuten eingebaut ich meine es ist ein toaster aber es kann vibrieren kein problem fünf minuten bei euch die ein alles vibriert und fällt dann runter ich baue es mal ein und dann ist ja die frage ob man es bewirbt oder nicht aber es ist wirklich nicht chef es ist wirklich überhaupt kein ich brauche es nicht hör mir zu ich habe sie als chef eingestellt. Es ist überhaupt kein Problem. Es ist weder finanziell noch vom Aufwand noch von der Produktion macht es irgendeinen Unterschied. Wir können einfach einen Vibrationsmotor reinbauen. Es ist wirklich, wirklich überhaupt kein Problem. Da hast du schon recht. Und wenn sie es nicht benutzen. Ja, genau. Aber es macht wirklich keinen Unterschied. Außerdem haben wir so viele gekauft, dass der Mehrpreis fast keine Rolle spielt. Wir sind technisch so weit, also wirklich, auch dank Ihnen, auch weil Sie wirklich vorangehen und diese Firma nach vorne bringen, sind wir technisch, ja, wirklich. Dankeschön. Sind wir so weit, dass es kein Ding ist. Voll okay, super, bauen Sie es ein. Wissen Sie was, bauen Sie zwei ein. Okay, kein Problem. Aber die müssen dann synchronisiert sein. Sonst was? Sonst passiert ja gar nichts. Wenn du zwei Vibrationsmotoren hast und wenn der eine hochgeht, geht der andere runter, dann passiert ja wieder gar nichts. Findest du, ist das wirklich, was du denkst? Das ist wirklich, was ich denke. Das ist abseits des Sketches, wirklich, was du denkst. Naja, wenn die nah genug zusammen sind, oder? Wenn der eine hochzieht, zieht der andere runter, dann passiert ja gar nichts. Ich denke mir, die müssen sich trotzdem bewegen. Ja, du hast schon recht, vielleicht passiert gar nichts. Vielleicht passiert gar nichts. Sie sind ja nicht so eng zusammen, die stoßen sich dann so an. Das ist die Frage, wenn die weit auseinander sind, dann ... Falls ihr Vibrationsexperten seid, schreibt uns gerne. Kerzen für Massage, macht man die an mit so betörendem Duft? Denn da lässt man dann so Wachs drauf tropfen oder was? Oh, nee, weiß ich nicht, nee. Nee, aber was, Kerze für Massage, was soll das denn bedeuten? Wie groß ist diese Kerze, dass sie in den Adventskalender passt? Teelicht. So drei Minuten Kerze. Nee, das ist riesig groß, dieser Adventskalender. Das ist ein Schrank, das ist ein kompletter Schrank. Kaufst du einen Adventsschrank? Aber genau diese ganzen Diskussionen, diese Überlegungen, hatte irgendeine Person, Person, sag mal, ich näher mich mit grossen Schritten im Schlaganfall, sehen wir ins Gesicht. Also wirklich. Es ist so merkwürdig, weil du sprichst eloquent as fuck, jedes Wort sitzt und ist immer das Letzte, was du einfach verreist, verreist es. Das ist ja schon Feierabend einfach. Mein Gehirn sagt Feierabend, wo man die letzten Zeit weiterkommt, mach ich morgen. Das ist ja kein Problem jetzt. Da sass einfach eine Person, weil du von Perversion kommst. Oh, finde ich gut. In deinem Köpfchen. Das kann gut sein. Irgendeine Person hatte all diese Gedanken an der Rewe-Kasse und gesagt hat, komm, schmeiß rauf.
Hast du es gesehen?
Ich habe es nicht gesehen. Ich habe genau auf die Box geguckt, in der diese Adventskalender kamen und habe gesehen, dass von der Breite der Adventskalender ungefähr vorne schon eine Lücke von zwei Stück ist. Also dass schon zwei rausgenommen wurden. Ja, ich sehe da so einen Vater, so einen Ü50 Dad, der dann so Gaggeschenk für Uwe mässig den dann so mitnimmt. Ich vergesse bei Erotik immer den Spaßfaktor, immer die Comedy, immer den ironisches Geschenk. Ich glaube eh, dass die Erotikbranche zu 80 Prozent wahrscheinlich von Gaggeschenken lebt. Auch so Dilden und so werden wahrscheinlich zum grossen Teil für Uwe, von Hans-Peter für Uwe gekauft oder von Uwe für Hans-Peter. Diese Sexshops sind doch nur Geschenke für den 18. Geburtstag irgendwie. Wer geht da ernsthaft rein? Ja, weiss ich nicht. Na gut, ja. Wir wissen zu wenig. Jedenfalls, ehrlich gesagt, ich als Binder und Sparfuchs, ich lieb das zu sparen. Ich sehe, der kostet 60 Euro und da steht gross darauf Warenwert 650 Euro jetzt hier einer. Das spart so wahnsinnig viel, wenn du die alle auspackst und weiterverkaufst. Genau, du verkaufst die Dinge unterjährig, verkaufst du die wieder weiter. Ja. Antirezessiv. Genau. Rezessiv. Nee, unterjährig. Ich weiß nicht, was unterjährig bedeutet. Nicht an den Rändern, ich kenne das. Ach so, okay, so in der Mitte des Jahres. Und aber dann oberjährig wäre dann an den Enden des Jahres oder was? Oder im zweiten Teil des Jahres ist es oberjährig? Das Wort klingt so was. Das klingt so, das klingt so, ist so ein hartes Erwachsenenwort. Es klingt so spezifisch, dass das, was es beschreibt, zu gross ist eigentlich. Ich glaube, Unterjährig beschreibt ja so abseits aller Saisonartikel. Ach so, abseits im normalen Jahr, so wie Wochentag, nicht Ostern, so wie Arbeitstag, ja, Werktag. Genau, Werktag, unterjährig. Aber es beschreibt halt zu viel des Jahres für so ein, das Wort klingt so, als würde es so zwei Tage im Jahr beschreiben. Gott spricht zu uns! Jahwe!
Das hört ihr übrigens immer nicht. Das ist der Grund, warum wir einmal pro Folge der Gottlob preisen, ist, weil wir die Glocken hören vom Kirchtum, die ihr nicht hört. Also all die Momente, wo ihr euch fragt, was ist dieser spontane religiöse Ausbruch hier, das sind immer die Kirchenglocken, denn wir sind ja hier in schönen Gölle. Würde Gott den Amborelli-Adventskalender A befürworten, B ignorieren oder C dich bestrafen, du musst ja irgendwie deinen Sohn, den Erstgeborenen töten oder sowas? Ich glaube, Gott hat erstmal auf alles Bock, was mit Weihnachten zu tun hat, da sagt er, ja, okay, erstmal gut, die wollen sich. Du meinst, er ist nach alledem immer noch Weihnachtsfan. Nach alledem, nach allem, was an Weihnachten passiert ist. Me meinst du weil er keine geschenke kriegt hat oder was ich meine nachdem es von coca-cola occupied wurde ein festes kapitalismus ist ach so das ist ja fein war kein weihnachten mehr nach all dem was passiert ist das kriegt er hier kommen die heiligen drei könige habe ich nichts gekriegt sagt mal häufiger den halbsatz nach allem was passiert, was passiert ist. Ja, das ist der beste Satz. Das finde ich total lustig. Sagt immer, einfach mal random einstreuen. Ist es okay, wenn du das Bier später zur Party mitbringst, nach allem, was passiert ist? Einfach eine ganz normale Frage. Nach allem, was passiert ist. Willst du wirklich nach Rügen fahren? Willst du dieses Jahr wirklich nach Rügen fahren? Ja., was passiert ist? Ja, genau. Ah, wie läuft's denn
mit Jessica, nach allem, was
passiert ist? Es passt nach jeder
Frage. Macht das eigentlich
die Welt, finde ich, es bringt
diese Würze, diese Dramatik drauf,
die ich mir wünsche. Willst du es wirklich
das Pinocchio-Eis, nach allem, was
passiert ist?
Ja. Und alle am Tisch
werden sich fragen, was ist alles, nach allem, weil es muss ja so viel passiert sein. Es muss eine Menge passiert sein. Es muss so viel passiert sein, ja. Sonst würde man es ja auch erwähnen. Genau, das Nicht-Erwähnen macht es ja gerade interessant. Du weisst, nach allem was passiert. Also man muss wirklich so ein nach vorne lehnen, le werden. Genau. Und das macht einfach noch spannender. Du willst wirklich die Gemüselasagne? Allem was passiert ist? Genau. Nach dem Köttbüller-Inzident. Ja, aber dann auch so ein... Na okay. Dann, wenn du dir das zutraust... Okay, dann bin ich jetzt mal gespannt, ob ... So, okay.
Das finde ich sehr lustig.
Das müsst ihr häufig immer machen, mit der Abmachung, dass niemand sagt, es ist doch nichts passiert, oder lachen. Nein, nein, nein, jeder muss mitspielen.
Alle am Tisch müssen mitspielen.
Alle müssen mitspielen, wenn jemand sagt zu dir vor Fremden, nach allem was passiert ist.
Willst du wirklich so nahe an der Kerze sitzen, nach allem was passiert ist?
Ja, okay, na gut, ist sehr klar. Naja, weil es ist. Willst du wirklich so nahe an der Kerze sitzen? Nach allem, was passiert ist. Ja, okay. Ist es sehr klar. Naja, war es auch nicht so. Kann trotzdem sein. Die Kerze. Hunde haben eine natürliche Angst vor Kerzen. Ja? Also Feuer ist mir aufgefallen. Und die verstehen, dass sie verbrennen können? Die Feuer ist ein Nein, Nein. Feuer, Feuer, Nein, Nein Okay, Feufeu. Und das fand ich schon interessant. Weil das so stark riecht. Und auch jetzt habe ich wieder, weiss nicht, jetzt habe ich auch wieder festgestellt, es gibt so als Interviewpartner Gerz, weiss ich nicht, keine Ahnung, aber was ich sagen wollte. Und aber war das dann letzten Endes nicht Wahlbetrug? Weiss ich nicht, aber ich weiß noch damals, ob der war. Aber keine Ahnung. Weil ich interessiere mich so doll für Instinkte, weil ich nicht weiss, wo die herkommen. Ja. Und da habe ich ja auch meine Philosophie-Klausur, die will ich jetzt nicht lesen, die lesen ich bald. Aber hier drin geht es auch um, was ist in uns drin? Das, was du vorgelegt hast. Also hier habe ich ja auch, aber ich werde nie darauf anspringen. Genau, und ich werde es auch nie mich entzaubern, indem ich diesen Unsinn vorlese, sondern immer sagen, ich hätte ja Philosophie im Abi. In dem Werk, was ich 2004 vorgelegt habe, habe ich ja das schon angerissen, dass die Instinkte ja durchaus... Genau, und hier frage ich mich, da ging es ja auch um Platon. Und da fährt man ja nach Platon mit einem Seelenwagen vor der Geburt durch, weiß nicht. Ja, du meinst in der Philosophie Plato. Genau, Plato fährt man mit dem Seelenwagen rum und kriegt schon alles Wissen reingeballert. Dann kommt man auf die Erde, dann kommt dieses Höhlen-Gleichen, das ist erstmal egal für dieses Beispiel, aber du hast schon intrinsisch irgendwas in dir drin, du hast schon, du weißt schon das Wissen und du musst es entblättern.
Jetzt ist aber für mich die Frage, das denkt ein bisschen nach Instinkt und es gibt, er hat ja auch in gewisser Weise recht. Manche Dinge hast du a priori in deinem Körper, wie zum Beispiel Hunde haben Angst vor Feuer, haben nicht unbedingt eine schlechte Erfahrung mit Feuer gemacht bislang, aber sie wissen, es ist nichts, sollte ich jetzt nicht anfassen. Ja. Es kann die gleisende Hitze sein, die es ausstrahlt. Einfach. Was hast du für Kerze, die gleisende Hitze ausstrahlt. Die sind so hell. Diese Amorelie-Adventskalender-Kerze.
Die ist so hell.
Und dann jetzt auch wieder, es gibt so Pixelbilder, die nach und nach kannst du ein Tier erkennen.
Und die werden so automatisiert besser sichtbar, alle.
Und Menschen können Schlangen viel früher erkennen.
Na gut, Schlangen ist jetzt auch eine recht simple Form, oder? Meinst du nicht? Nee, nee, das sind richtig komplexe Bilder. Es ist nicht einfach nur Wurm. Es ist nicht einfach nur so ein S. Nee, nee. Mit einem Kopf dran. Nein, nein, nein. Okay. Es sind komplexe Bilder, innen Natur versteckte Tiere und Schlangen können wirklich so 80% früher entdeckt werden, weil wir immer noch so eine Uhr, das ist ja auch mit Kindern, das kam ich ja neulich drauf, wenn man Babys über Gras hält, machen die die Beine hoch, weil die haben Angst vor dem Gras, wollen nicht reingesessen, weil die Schlange wartet. Wie kann ein fucking Tier so viel auslösen, also wie viel Angst kann eine gesamte Spezies Mensch vor einem anderen Tier haben, dass das so tief drin ist. Zuneite Frage, sieht es S aus, wie es aussieht, wegen Schlange? Nein. Ah, Snake auch eine neue Frage. Weil es einfach aussieht, wie eine Schlange, ist S? Puh. Also die Schlange hat, finde ich, viel zu viel Einfluss auf uns. Einfluss, aber dann finde ich es ja wieder toll, dass in meinem Lieblingsbuch der Bibel, das ja aufgegriffen wurde, als die Schlange als Personifikation des Teufels, dass genau dieses Tier dann wieder reingenommen wurde, weil es anscheinend so tief im Menschen drin ist. Aber Gott hat gesagt, wir dürfen den Apfel nicht essen. Er schmeckt so wunderbar. Er sieht auch wirklich wunderbar aus. Aber Eva, wir haben doch so viele andere Dinge hier im Paradies, die auch lecker schmecken.
Ihr wollt diesen Apfel.
Naja, jetzt wo du es sagst, Gott kann ja vielleicht auch nicht alles sehen.
Schmeckt süss und saftig.
Ach naja, was soll schon passieren, dann werde ich ja mal reinbeissen. Ist er nicht wunderbar? Oh, so süss, so süss und lecker. Etwas Besseres habe ich noch nie gegessen. Du willst mehr davon. Ich will noch mehr Äpfel essen. So, und ich hoffe, dass Rufux Beck das genau so eingesprochen hat. Genau so will ich das eingesprochen haben, nicht anders. Was sind deine Lieblings-Apfelsorten? Also, naja, ich mag Boskop. Eigentlich eine geile Apfelwerbung in der Bibel-Teile. War es alles nur eine Apfelwerbung? Meine Satans-Tierstimme war inspiriert vom Film The Witch, den ich sehr empfehlen kann, von Robert Eggers. Müssen wir jetzt Quellen offenlegen oder was? Ist das jetzt die Idee, dass wir Quellenangaben machen im Podcast? Toller Film, weil ich habe den Grusel Oktober eingeleitet. Für Halloween ist bald jetzt auch, also wenn die Folge rauskommt, war es schon. Ihr habt euch schon gegruselt, ist schon vorbei. Ihr habt schon dieses herrliche, katharsische Gefühl, dass euch diese Extremsituation gereinigt hat auf irgendeine Art. Wir haben die noch nicht. Wir haben die noch nicht, wir sind noch schmuddelig und filthy. Und da habe ich jetzt The Witch geguckt und da spricht der Teufel so. Und es ist total, diese Szene ist wahnsinnig angsteinflösend und toll. Das ist das mit der Ziege. Genau, und der Geistbock sagt dann ja irgendwann im Off, man sieht ihn nicht, aber er sagt, what does I want? Und es ist der erste Satz von diesem Ziegenbock, den man plötzlich hört und es ist so angsteinflössend. Und die erste Idee wäre ja, man nimmt so einen Rufus Beck-artigen, tief sprechenden Menschen. Ja. Sprechender so tief, weiß ich gar nicht mehr. Aber so, was willst du? Aber das ist ja viel uncooler, als wenn man einfach so eine... Ja, da hat er so was Ziegenhaftes. Was willst du, was willst? Was willst du, Mami? Was ist es, was du mir gehörst? Hätten wir natürlich auch eine Möglichkeit. Boah, das wäre so verstörend gewesen, ehrlich gesagt. Auch eine andere Möglichkeit, diesen Ziegenbock. Andere Idee. Bock. Ist eine andere Idee. Oft kann man ja alles machen, sage ich ja immer. Deswegen sage ich ja bei dir immer, weil das Problem bei deinen Sachen ist, dass die Leute zu sehr im Bild stehen, weil du kannst dann ja nicht mehr im Nachhinein ändern, was sie sagen, weil du hast ja die Lippen. Ich sage immer, gute Filme haben keine Lippen, deine Zooms machen mich wahnsinnig. Auf die Lippen immer, die Lippen. Zoom doch lieber auf die Augen oder die Ohren oder so, dann kann man im Nachhinein noch sagen, immer in den Ohren. So kannst du ja immer noch mit reinbringen dann so. Ich gucke die noch eine Möglichkeit. Ja, naja. Du gruselst dich aber dann nur in der Zeit gerne oder? Ich liebe den Oktober dafür, dass ich gerne jeden Abend Halloween, zeige auch gerne Horrorfilme, genau, zeige ich gerne, liebe ich. Dann läuft es dir eiskalt den Rücken runter. Es geht, ich gucke die ganz gern und klar habe ich da noch Angst vor, ich habe noch so ein Kissen in der Hand,
Angst vor Jumpscares, aber
so allgemein schockt mich.
Ich kenne die meisten ja auch. Ich kenne wirklich sehr viele Horrorfilme.
Und dann, wenn der Film vorbei ist, dann hast du noch so
Angst, dass so eine Ziege in deiner Wohnung steht
oder so, oder? Ich habe eine chronische
Angst vor Rückbänken, Autorückbänken zum Beispiel.
Oh ja. Weil das ist wirklich
gröslich. Finde ich gut.
Und auch wenn Leute Freunde dann nach Hause fahren,
nach dem Horrorfilmabend, sag dir noch mal so einen Satz
Vielen Dank. vor Rückbänken, Autorückbänken zum Beispiel. Oh ja. Weil das ist wirklich gruselig. Finde ich gut. Und auch wenn Leute Freunde nach Hause fahren, nach dem Horrorfilmabend, sagt denen nochmal so einen Satz wie Schört, schön auf dem Rücksichtssitz hinter euch. Also lieber auf dem Rücksicht achten. Weil das sind so Dinge, die kann man dann auch nicht vergessen. Da hat man auch Angst. Ne, genau, bislang lief in Stefans Movie Nights schon It Follows. Ja. Nur zu empfehlen, toller, toller Film. Viel Jumpscares. Also wer keinen Bock auf Jumpscares hat, It Follows ist manchmal ein bisschen gemein auch, ein bisschen billig, aber ist ein sehr cooler Film. Sehr toller Film. Aber manchmal einfach so, da gibt es Szenen, wo man sich denkt, da steht dann irgendwie so die Protagonistin im Bad und dann ist es so ganz still und nichts passiert und dann fliegt plötzlich ein Ball außen gegen das Fenster. So und dann denkt ihr, okay, okay, okay. Wird nie aufgeklärt. Wird nie aufgeklärt, wer hat den Ball geworfen. Das ist der wahre Horror für mich. Dass nie aufgeklärt wurde, warum da Bälle gegen den Ball fliegen. Genau, wer wirft einfach einen Ball gegen das Fenster. Das Fenster hätte kaputt gehen können. Das ist der Alltagshorror, der dich beschäftigt. Absolut, das Fenster hätte einfach kaputt gehen können. Ja. So. Und das willst du nicht. Das willst du wirklich nicht. Nee, wenn du einen Dämon willst, der Zugriff zum Haus will. Nee. Meine grösste Angst ist, wirklich ein Fenster zu zerstören. Weil ich wüsste dann, also bei manchen Dingen, wenn man sich denkt, oh, verdammt, Dinge im Haushalt gehen kaputt oder so, dann denkt man, na, das ist schlecht, aber ich weiss grob, wie ich es händle. Kaputtes Fenster, ich wäre wirklich blank. Ich habe jetzt meine Glasversicherung gekündigt. Das ist sehr lustig, dass du das jetzt sagst, weil ich will schon vor einer Woche Und das vor Halloween. Na Stefan, Arroganz kommt vor dem Fall, möchte ich dir sagen. Das ist sehr spannend, dass du jetzt mir sagst. Sagen! Satan! Mein Gott, der Ziegenbock spricht mit mir. Also an welchem Punkt sagt man, nee, ich fühle mich sicher, dass mein Glas nicht zu Bruch geht. Ich bin meine Versicherung durchgegangen. Einfach so oder mit einer App? Nachdem wir oft darüber sprechen, habe ich gesagt, du empfiehlst es immer allen, vielleicht solltest du selber mal deine Versicherung durchgehen und den Bedarfscheck machen. Papiergeldfrei oder was? Papierkramfrei. Papiergeldfrei.
Nee, nicht ganz Papiergeldfrei. Jedenfalls
ist mir aufgefallen,
ich habe da diese Glasversicherung,
warum auch immer, ich erinnere mich auch nicht,
die abgeschlossen zu haben. Ja, ist aber jetzt einfach nicht dumm, finde ich.
Du hast viel Glas.
Ich habe auch eine Hausratsversicherung.
Aber eine Hausglasversicherung
ist so komisch.
Aber Rad ist ja, man kann es ja nicht sehen. Rad ist ja nur Dinge, die man sehen kann. Ich würde aber behaupten, wenn das Fenster kaputt geht, musst du dafür nicht aufkommen, sondern der Vermieter oder die Wohngemeinschaft. Wenn der Dämon durchs Fenster in deine Wohnung kommt, weil er dich verfolgt. Achso, da habe ich dafür eine Dämonenversicherung. Ah, okay, super. Das ist ja gut. Eine Supernatural-Dämonenversicherung. Bitte nicht vergessen, die ist super billig, die kostet nur ein paar Cent pro Monat, aber wenn dann mal irgendwie das ganze Haus verwüstert wird. Ey, wollen wir eine Versicherungsfirma gründen, die heisst das Podcast UFO und da drin sind Versicherungen aufgeführt für so, also die sind wahnsinnig billig alle, wahnsinnig billig, aber so für so Dinge, die nicht, wahrscheinlich nicht passieren, wie zum Beispiel, oh ein Dämon, ich habe aus Versehen eine Rechtsschutzversicherung für diese Kreuzungsdämonen, die bei Supernatural gab es die immer, du verkaufst deine Seele für etwas. Und dann bist du in so einem Recht, das lässt nicht ein juristischer Streit. So eine Rechtsschutzversicherung mit Dämonen, weil die sind schon noch gewieft. Eine Rechtsschutzversicherung für Diskussionen mit Dämonen. Also Advocati, Diavoli, die dir helfen im Umgang mit dem Teufel. Und Dämonenpakten. Also sie haben einen Dämonenpakt eingegangen, aber sie haben das Gefühl, dass der Teufel sie über den Tisch gezogen hat. Das ist ganz normal. Kommen sie zu uns. In Dämonentrakten, in Dämonenverträgen ist man häufig auf sich alleine gestellt. Nicht mit uns. Wir helfen ihnen. Wir stellen ihnen Top-Juristen, irdische, geben wir ihnen an die Hand. Ja, aber es kostet für 10 Cent im Monat. Super, das ist so billig. Selbst wirklich vernünftige, aufgeklärte Menschen denken sich, ich glaube nicht an Geister, aber es sind wirklich nur zehn Cent im Monat. Ja. Und ich meine, du musst ja immer Wahrscheinlichkeit und Risiko irgendwie aufwägen. Sie wurden von Aliens entführt und haben Freunde und Familie und ihren Job verloren? We got you. Für nur sieben Cent im Jahr können sie bei uns in die Alienversicherung. Für zwei Cent im Jahr helfen wir ihnen, Ihr Leben wieder auf die Reihe zu bekommen nach einer Alienobduction. Komm, Clara, das machen wir. Komm, das machen wir. Zwei Cent im Jahr. Ist nichts. Ich verliere mehr Geld aus Versehen. Die Werbung hat viertausend Euro gekostet. Meine Hosen haben mehr Geld in Intus, als diese Versicherung kosten würde. Weil ich mal so zwei Cent in Hosen vergesse. Ja, ständig. Ich glaube, es ist eine gute Idee. Klar, ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass es rechtlich ein bisschen schwierig wird, weil ich glaube, es ist nicht so simpel eine Versicherung zu gründen, würde ich jetzt erst mal naiv annehmen, aber wir können es probieren. Devil's Advocate. Wir können es probieren. Also habt ihr Bock, ihr könnt ja meine Kommentare schreiben, ob ihr Bock drauf habt, schreibt es uns Reddit, wie viel würdet ihr zahlen, wie viel Cent und hättet ihr Lust und was würdet ihr mindestens als Gegenleistung erwarten, also dass wir sagen, wir haben Salz, wir können einen Bannkreis, wir haben Knoblauch da, also alles relativ günstig. Glasversicherung oder so eine Möbelversicherung gegen Poltergeister. Genau. Oh nein, hat denn Poltergeist schon wieder ihr ganzes Südstaatenhaus verwüstet? Wir rücken es wieder gerade. Wir machen alles, genau, nicht mit der Poltergeistversicherung, dann kann Ihnen das nicht passieren. Sie müssen beweisen, dass es ein Poltergeist war und nicht sie selbst. No, aber es ist ein Problem. Das ist natürlich das Problem, was sind unsere Standards dann zu beweisen, dass es wirklich ein Dämon war und nicht der Hund. Am Ende hat man wahrscheinlich massiven Hundschaden und am Ende müssen wir den ganzen Hundschaden reparieren und die Leute sagen, es war ein Dämon. Ja, das stimmt, da müssen wir wirklich, das heisst, wir würden dann prophylaktisch das ganze Haus mit Kameras ausstatten, um zu sehen.
Oder nur den Hund.
Oder nur die Dusche. Okay, Dusche und den Hund mit Kameras ausstatten. Genau. Und dann können wir genau sehen, was der Hund gemacht hat. Dann können wir genau sehen, ob ein Dämon im Spiel war. Ja. Weil die einfach auch in der Dusche auftauchen. Ja, wir melden uns bei euch.
Ja, gut.
Ich glaube, da müssen wir noch mal ran. Wir ziehen uns noch mal ins Hauptquartier zurück, denken das durch.
Wir denken uns noch mal eine Woche durch. Genau, vielleicht seht ihr dann
schon irgendwann die Werbung für das Podcast Ufo,
die Versicherung für alles Nicht-Irdische.
Ansonsten wünschen wir euch eine ganz tolle Woche. Haut rein, macht's gut. Wir sehen uns dann auch
nächste Woche schon wieder an gleicher Stelle. Macht's gut.
Macht's gut, Towie!
It's a worst bird production. April 1923, Arktischer Ozean. Es wird noch lange dauern, bis ein Schiff kommt.
Hey, wir sind Olontore und das war ein Ausschnitt aus einer typischen Folge unseres Podcasts Wild und Fremd. Wir erzählen die Geschichten von historischen Expeditionen, von Abenteurerinnen und Entdeckern ganz eng an ihren persönlichen Tagebüchern.
Wenn ihr Bock habt auf krasse, wahre Storys über wilde, fremde Welten, dann gebt Wild und Fremd im Podcastplayer eurer Wahl ein.